there are times when i feel the stress
of the circumstances
um and then i can at will
go out of that stress first thing i had
to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself every skill is difficult
at first until you
practice it and then train until you get
to a place
where you master it want to be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some of the
habits and mindsets of
billionaires enjoy
okay let's stick it off with rule number
one view things
differently with ray dalio when you find
yourself under stress
and anxiety things go wrong you get
disappointments
things don't work out as you hoped you
must feel a moment of anxiety a moment
of stress
how do you deal with that what happens
um
i can go out of the stress
i can at at any moment like there are
times when i i feel the stress
of the circumstances um and then i can
at will go out of that stress
and just see things in a different way
and it makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that
makes me feel more centered and in
control but like tennis players
they say at the height of their game the
ball seems to go much slower
the whole game yeah and it's really
that equanimity that produces
that kind of a reaction as distinct from
when you have the anxiety there's not
the clarity there's
it's all coming too fast rule number two
take
time to learn with mark cuban i always
try to hire people that are smarter than
me and that complement my skills
skill sets like i'm a ready fire aim guy
and i always try to partner with people
that are very anal and perfectionist to
kind of balance me out or have a skill
set that i don't have
um but once i'm going i mean i would go
to events
and like this and listen and learn and
go to conferences
and when i get the opportunity i'll ask
questions
but i'm not i i can't ever say ever
where i've said
i'm gonna call this guy and just see
what he thinks for this woman and just
ask that's just not my style i mean
because at some point i'm going to have
to be responsible for whatever that
knowledge is
and and and also i have the benefit of
being in the technology business
and it's it's a benefit because there's
always something new coming
and i've always had the attitude that
whatever it is so if it's virtual
reality if it's the oculus rift
it's new to everybody except the people
who invented it and so
i'm i'm at first base like everybody
else
and then it's just a question of effort
of learning it as well as everybody else
so other than going to the originator of
the idea concept product service
whatever
i'm tied with everybody else and and
having the opportunity to learn it so
i'll just put in the time to learn it
so from a tech perspective and that
that's always served me well because
once you understand
these different products you understand
how they fit together and it also helps
you make decisions and understand what
will work and what won't work
rule number three work twice as hard
with elon musk
certainly being focused on something
that
you're confident will have high value to
someone else
and just being really rigorous in making
that assessment
um because people tend to
natural human tendency is wishful
thinking
so a challenge for entrepreneurs is to
say well what's the difference between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking to sticking to them
versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to
to tell you can you tell the difference
between those two things so you need to
be sort of
very rigorous um in your self self
analysis
um i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and and then just
work like hell i mean you just have to
put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour weeks
every week
because and then a lot of work that
all those things improve the odds of
success okay um
i mean if if if other people are putting
in 40 hour work weeks and you're putting
in
100 hour work weeks then even if
uh you're doing the same thing you know
that in in
one year you will achieve what they
achieve you will achieve
in four months what it takes them a year
to achieve
rule number four improve yourself with
grant cardone
you guys are just getting started you're
not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money
raised by a single mother i was in debt
at 25 years old
the first thing that i had to do in my
life was not
learn a new skill first thing i had to
do
to get my life moving in the right
direction was self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me
i had to show up every day with some
rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself
to do the right thing every day one of
the things that i started doing was
beating the sun up every morning
i'm gonna beat that sun up every morning
so that i had the discipline and the
control of over my life
so i knew hey before that thing pops
i'm gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself
get up at the same time every day and
for me that time regardless of where i
was
was beat that sun up no matter where i
am i'm gonna beat that thing up
so it gives me a sense of control over
my own life second thing
i had to start cleaning up my life and
my friends and my environment
when i was younger between 15 and 25 i
was doing
crazy stuff in my life wasting my
weekends i have the same weekends or for
the week
i was drinking fooling around with a
bunch of
bad things bad people making poor
choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places
quit using those things quit hanging out
with people that did not have
ethics and discipline in their life that
weren't committed to the same things
that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone
and to do that to become someone in the
eyes of the world
the first thing i had to do was become
someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick start your day get going in your
day
to give you a sense of respect for
yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning
gives me the sense of accomplishment
that i did what i said
said i was gonna do that i woke up when
i said i would wake up
and i start building respect for myself
start believing in myself
so that i can go out into the world and
maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when i go into
this meeting
that i'm dressed for maybe they'll
believe in me as much as i believe in me
and that'll show up in a contract a deal
maybe even some money
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five practice
new skills with robin sharma if you
practice
any new skill for 66 days in a row
through the power of neuroplasticity
which is the brain's ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term
automaticity in other words after 66
days of practicing the 20 20 20 formula
and joining the 5 a.m club and running
the morning routine you're going to get
to a point
where it's automatic you're going to get
to a point where it's actually easier to
get up at 5 a.m
than to stay in in bed i also want to
offer you a brain tattoo from the book
to consider as you wire in this
learning protocol of billionaires and
highly creative people
professional athletes and industry
titans and it's this
all change is hard at first and it's
messy in the middle and it's beautiful
at the end
i'm going to repeat that again for you
because it's so important all change is
hard at first
if a new skill or a new routine
or a new habit was easy then it wouldn't
be valuable change
so anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you
that whether it's a great morning
routine whether it's building a great
business whether it's releasing your
master work to the world maybe it's a
great relationship
maybe it's a great interior life it
takes
real effort it takes the long game it
takes focus it takes hard work
it takes bravery but the rewards are so
much more glorious than living an easy
life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found
difficult you now find easy
little kids for example find walking
early on difficult or learning
a new nursery rhyme or learning how to
read or learning how to build
relationships at first there's not a lot
of
facility and fluency with those skills
because every skill is difficult at
first until you
practice it and then train until you get
to a place
where you master it and so your morning
routine is going to be challenging at
first but with
daily training and practicing the 20 20
20 formula
i promise you you're going to get to a
point of mastery and then the payoffs
are extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize
you will actually attract more
prosperity into your life because the
marketplace rewards
true creativity and productivity you're
going to feel so much more happier
in your day you're going to find that
sense of peacefulness so it's almost
like
you go through a life with a greater
level of grace
and ease you know the way you start your
day
determines the way your day is going to
unfold and rule number six the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is balance work and play with richard
branson
i mean the balance of work and play is
critical
and i think a lot of people don't get
that balance right you know i'm 63 years
old now
so uh critical to find time for yourself
and get out there and keep fit and and i
find the best way of keeping fit is by
playing
i try to encourage our chief executives
worldwide to make sure that there's as
much flexibility in in the workplace
as possible we've set up something
called the b team which is examining
the way companies treat their staff and
trying to make suggestions to make the
dignity of work
better than it's been in the past
[Music]
if you're too close to a situation like
in an office
you get bogged down with the manuta if
you can step away from the situation
you can think about the bigger picture
and that's what
i'm able to do on that
the most extraordinary people come to
necca the elders was conceived here on
mecca with archbishop tutu with
president carter with kofi annan
the carbon wall room was conceived here
an organization that tries to work with
industry to try to
extract carbon out of the earth's
atmosphere you know sitting
in muhammad looking up at the stars at
night things like virgin galactic
so great place to think and a great
place to conceive ideas
well we had a fantastic day it was a
sunday so it wasn't all work
so um a great way of capping off the day
watch the super bowl
with a cup of tea and uh and a chair
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place and how you're
going to actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you start preparing the night before
most people have great morning routines
they start the night before
when you actually have a little bit more
time so instead of trying to cram
everything in
to that hectic ridiculously crazy
morning
help make it easier for yourself by
planning a little
bit more the night before so if you're
one of your goals is to exercise and to
run more
the night before set out your shoes set
up your exercise gear
set up your clothes so that all you have
to do is wake up and put them on
if one of your goals is to eat healthier
and you're tired of going out and eating
mcdonald's for lunch or whatever it is
then the night before plan your lunch
make a sandwich make a salad
create something healthy have some
snacks you can just
go to the fridge pull out your bag and
you're off to work today's my video day
when i know it's my video day the night
before i set up my camera i set up my
gear set up my microphone it's all ready
for me to go so all i have to do is walk
in
and press record and i'm ready to go
make it easy for yourself don't
cram more into your morning prepare the
night before
[Music]
if you want even more insights into how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you have to do something for
10 minutes minimum if you don't have 10
minutes you don't have a life
usually before the sun comes up i offer
myself
to something greater than myself
[Music]